[Musique]
non vous n'assistez pas à la mise à feu
d'une fusée interplanétaire guettée par
le mystère nocturne de l'espace vous
êtes en Pologne à l'est de la Vistule
sur l'un des 2000 lacs de
masuri découpé comme les pièces
disjointes d'un gigantesque jeu de
patience argenté
disséminé parmi les forêts les plus
denses
d'Europe c'est l'heure où le pêcheur
allume son fanal pour aller relever ses
casiers formant dans la nuit d'encre
avec les autres embarcation lointaines
un étrange balai d'étoile ralenti
au-dessus des eau
[Musique]
ici sur d'immenses étendues la nature
est restée elle-même sans addition ni
soustraction de main d'homme belle comme
au premier jour vous la voyez àaube
sortir du frémissement de l'onde comme
du fond d'un bain photographique et vous
la verrez prendre tour à tour sous vos
yeux toutes les délicatesses du pastel
les tremblements lumineux de
impressionisme les finesses du dessin
japonais les formes touffuses et
irrespirables de
vangog la précision minutieuse des
enluminures l'extension irréelle des
lointains de
breuguel la blancheur ailée et fuyante
des oiseaux de Brac et pour être complet
les chatoimements indécis les taches
dansantes les paraboles et les lignes
concertantes de la peinture
abstraite nous vous invitons à constater
par l'image qu'en fait d'art il y a
assez longtemps que la nature a tout
[Rires]
inventé
ce n'est pas un document touristique que
nous vous présentons aujourd'hui c'est
un cours complet de peinture à l'état
[Musique]
sauvage mais c'est aussi une partie de
pêche et les pêcheurs détestent que l'on
parle autour d'eux je me
tais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]